oh that's a good question i'm not even
sure I feel like every year when I go to
the family reunion I always meet someone
new our families our families definitely
like we definitely have like over in the
hundreds that attend that family reunion
it's a weekend and also can I just want
to say this presentation that I do with
my family it's usually like 30-45 minute
presentation so I really cut it down and
have a lot of other stories that I could
add to it but yeah it's a whole weekend
of events there's we've done cruises the
big of main event is the picnic that we
have every Sunday there's a brunch
there's lots of events like hundreds of
people it's a big
mm-hmm want to say my mom is here today
too so she could probably add a little
bit more I've been a little out of touch
since I've been here I started school in
January I know one of the major things
that they're trying to do now in terms
of organizing and being able to have
more powers they're trying to get
nonprofit I think it's co 3 co 3 1
status they're trying to enforce it as a
non-profit community so that they're
able to do more advocacy if you want to
add I think still on my family and
they're probably about I'll say about 28
but the question that she had she wanted
to know like the ad because he thing
like the meetings that you and I bet
have been going on to the board we've
been going we've been meeting that the
city is very much aware of of this
community and that it was a hidden
community until the sarah said they
built washington avenue extension nobody
even knew we existed there and then it
became prime real estate and now
developers are trying to take this land
which my family owns relatives own and
as she as Sarah said as some are dying
off and mostly children their children
are taking their homes but for those
that didn't their developers are buying
it and then we have gone to the to the
City Hall and Albany and have that when
they go for board hearings for
the right for zoning rights we have gone
there and forces I mean as many as 20 30
of us showing up at these hearings and
testifying explaining the importance and
a sentimental value of this land so
they're listening to us and they're
saying they're not allowing the
development to take place and but it's
because of the Zoning Board that's you
know that has been supportive of us
knowing of our family history and at the
road that closes also every year it's a
road that's owned by our family it was
my grandfather's wrote it was part of
his Road and so for because of eminent
domain we shut it down for the weekend
once a year during family reunion to let
them know that we are not relinquishing
that property that road the city has
even actually offered to buy it I hope I
answered the question I know I can be
long way and more oh I don't I guess I
just wanted to say I think it's
interesting how everything kind of tied
in together we talked about cultural
competency talked about power and
privilege and then we had like an
example of power versus privilege in
fighting back against the system but I
guess I wanted to address something with
with cultural competency understanding
like who you are and what you bring into
the room because I felt like you were
speaking as a social worker you bring
into the room your perceptions and your
prejudices against other other folks so
I just would want to know like in a in a
scenario when you say I have a Mexican
Chinese person in front of me so they
mix together you don't know how they
view themselves what would you say is
the most important part of just that
initial interaction a source close for
competency I think when you're in front
of a person and a Mexican Chinese maybe
you're there not that many assumptions
you're gonna make or maybe they are I
don't know but I think asking questions
and like with any person that's sitting
in front of you
you we all always like just looking at
the person the clothes are wearing their
color of their skin the way they speak
you start making judgments and
assumptions and I address the the point
of culture and like how we do make
assumptions on culture so being aware of
that we are making those assumptions i
think it's it's a good start and how do
you address it when you're sitting in
front of that person will be aware of
how you're making those assumptions like
I think it's awareness of yourself of
what's coming up coming up for you and I
thing and it's not easy and it's like I
don't know yeah and I think like I just
touched the surface of it and like I I
agree with you i'm I'm Mexican I am a
dual citizen I grew up in Mexico I'm and
I'm living here now and when I say
Mexican there's certain things that like
RSL like their assumptions made and like
maybe there's a like the Latino caucus
the Latino caucus gets together and has
meetings and i don't i don't feel part
of it I don't feel I relate so so I
understand what you're saying like there
are certain things that you need to see
each person is how that person I don't
yeah that's when you can see as much on
the surface you know like how do you
today for a lot of a difficult day so
it's a weird day go by you go with your
day and then you're sort of like okay
remember really you know how do you
address something and be culturally like
always you think Iran to is how do you
address something well I guess that's
part of why I spoke about cultural
competency because what does that really
mean and how do we become culturally
competent and can we become culturally
competent there's so many different
aspects to it unlike as you say like
today is a hard day for certain people
because of what you're saying but maybe
a lot of people don't know and if you're
sitting with a client in front of you
you need to explore that and see what
that means to that person and if you're
working in a community to develop a
program then you need to see what
community you're working with and what
things are that community has in common
what they don't because maybe that is
you're going to deal with it in one way
and someone else is going to deal in
another way but there's certain things
that will be in common because of that
cultural background so I'm like bringing
up the question of how do we do that
because like I don't have the answer
yeah
I'm Blaine anyway I just said I cannot
answer the question but for me the way I
answer that question for my experience
right now and I definitely don't the
answer finally learn it but in my
internship this year that's like
everything I'm I'm in an orthodox jewish
agency so I've been at worst and every
day is like a cultural competency like
Leslie literally I was in a different
placement in the beginning of the year
and I was learning like how to be a
clinician you know now it's like how far
do I have to stand hard like what
happened my yarmulke fall is awfully all
I think about all day long he's like
don't put out my hand shake someone so i
have to literally reprogram myself to be
a good member in the community that I'm
in and I think it's like what you said
the first thing you said is that as
social workers and students it's our job
to just kind of you know come to the
table and do our best even though we
might have this like preset of judgment
like oh you're wearing a gray or
whatever breathe you know people really
agreeing or sad i don't know maybe I
think that whoops stop but um but it's
my job to them like I guess hold that
and be like okay well let's meet her
let's see which is that it should happen
today you know and just like do that
opposed to put my stuff on what I think
about my like exploring yeah yeah we
have time for one more question or okay
two more questions we'll go back there
yeah um I think additionally and I can
have my mom add into it but it started
with my great aunt emma she just started
to do research on our family and our
family history I think there were a lot
of questions in my family just about
where we came from and how it came to be
just the history of rap road has been
passed down like orally you know from
generation to generation but I think
that and then Jennifer LeMat getting
involved it just sort of evolved and
developed into this whole thing with the
book and you know advocacy for the
community and keeping them unit
community together um like I said I just
moved to New York in January so I'm not
extremely familiar i know that Harlem
has a lot of things going on there i
think one of the things that I even I'll
say like I've we've discussed in class a
lot of there's been debates over things
that are going on in Harlem the
development where you know it's like
people want to come in and make it
better and do all this stuff and develop
it but then at the same time you have to
okay you want to make the community
better but you still have to preserve
you know what was there that legacy that
that historic you know part of it and I
know there's a lot of issues going
around to around Colombia being so close
to Harlem and some people actually
considering Columbia part of harlem and
taking over so i think it's you know
that balance i'm really into like
community i did some community research
on my undergrad and i think going out
into the community and asking people so
instead of uh she's coming in and
telling you what you need why don't we
find out what you want you know just
like with rap road having our family
have input in the development okay so
you bought this land we you know what
ideally like to keep it in the family we
have it well at least let us have some
input on what you want to do with it
let's come up with it together and build
it together yeah
okay we've got our panelists waiting
outside so unless there's a really
burning question we're going to give a
round of applause for our student
presenters